so i want to jump in right from the
beginning and sort of ask you
are you prepared for the amount of
families that are actually going to do
yesterdays as a result of this film
and the happy and angry emails you will
probably get
you know i think that people are
dreading the idea of yesterday
more than actually during the day of
yesterday parents are it's very
liberating for parents you know
because as parents you have to set
boundaries
all day long and all of a sudden to have
a day where you're like
i don't have to do that it's very
refreshing
so i hope that parents will be thanking
me i am curious
when you're making a film like this when
you have a lot of you know kids
in the shoot and a lot of things like
from a party scene to
filming with roller coasters and ice
cream how much are you looking at the
schedule
and sort of thinking about where you
want to shoot certain sequences
and how much is it sort of like whatever
the production
decides we're going to just do it that
way um
everything has to be pretty calculated
because you have so many people in a
film shoot and especially when you're
working with children you have limited
hours
and you want to be you know have
everything very planned
so you know it was fun though because
for example
the crew and the cast lived these things
for many days we ate ice cream
for two days we did a water balloon
where we threw more than 30
000 balloons for five days and then
we uh you know went to the roller
coaster park for
three days it it was uh exhausting but
extremely fun i gave my cat a yes day
for this interview
i see that right yeah
what's your cat's name uh this is marlo
and marlo never gets to be on camera but
today marlo does
it's a yes day yes um but i did hear
that you shot the
the ice cream stuff on the first two
days which i think is just
daunting because that's like you know
the day everyone's getting to meet each
other and now you're gonna give these
children
gallons upon gallons of ice cream what
was that like
well i did my very best to help them i
ate a lot of ice cream first of all we
ordered from my favorite
ice cream store in los angeles scoops
and uh
and the whole crew also helped you know
uh it was a little bit daunting but
you know sometimes it's better to throw
people on the deep end of the pool
and just be like just know that this
movie is going to be relentless
you know once you're in it you're going
to stay in it and so we figured let's
just
get going uh i'm curious about the edit
and um what was it like in the editing
room uh did you have a much longer cut
were there a lot of deleted scenes
uh there was very little that we took
out the movie was very very carefully
planned
and there was one sequence where they
spent a little more time in the hospital
when edgar ramirez gets injured
and that was the only thing we took out
uh but we have a
incredible editor jay dube i worked with
him many times
and you know it was interesting neither
him or i have children
and i think we particularly love making
family movies because of that i think
uh uh we enjoyed cutting the movie
tremendously
in the third act there's a huge house
party with a ton of children
and destroying a house what exactly is
it like trying to corral
that many kids filming a party scene
it's pretty difficult when you put 25 11
year olds in
in a whole bunch of foam inside a set uh
initially that scene was going to happen
in the backyard but i thought let's move
it inside
because it will be more fun and and a
bigger spectacle to destroy that whole
home with foam
uh my production designer who had built
us this beautiful home was
horrified but i said i promise you this
is going to be fun but
on day one i couldn't believe how hard
it was to get the kids to stop
you know i would yell cut and they kept
going i was like guys we had like three
or four days to ruin this house let's
just take it easy let's face ourselves
my last thing for you um i was a fan of
your episode of succession in season one
i'm just curious when you when you
agreed to be a part of that you didn't
know it was going to be this huge hit
um what was it like being a part of that
series and are you planning on doing any
future episodes
i i would love to come back you know um
jesse amster is an incredible
uh writer and uh that cast is amazing
i was so proud to be part of it on the
very first year uh i hope i can come
back
on that note i gotta go i'm just gonna
say congrats on this movie i know it'll
be a big hit for you and netflix
have a great day thanks steven take care